cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us good morning david let's
start there with those five to 11 year
olds in the cdc approving the vaccine
for them a lot of parents have been
waiting for this what's the next step
all right so the fda last night said
that there's enough data and it makes
sense positives dramatically outweigh
negatives so the fda advisory committee
reviews it tuesday and then a week later
it goes to the cdc for review and then
we'll be out beginning of november so we
can start to vaccinate our young ones
and allow them to be safe in school and
hopefully get away from max over time
this is a big step 28 million kids on
the roster to get this shot
doctor with boosters now recommended for
all three shots has the definition
of being fully vaccinated changed and if
not will it
that's a good question jeff um
yeah i think it is going to i mean the
definition of being vaccinated really
was for the original strain of covid19
now that we have delta and now that we
also know that over time the vaccines
wane
in order to be protected so that you're
not going to have a breakthrough
infection you're going to need more
protection from these boosters and
that's what we're seeing now so i do
think it will change and you may over
time see some travel restrictions
require you to have that booster to go
to certain places
along those lines when people are
looking at whether to or to not get the
booster a couple questions your advice
on if people should if they are six
months out and then also mixing and
matching
there's no question get the booster you
need that extra immunity block the
breakthrough infections not just for
yourself but for spreading it to grandma
that person next door is getting cancer
chemotherapy we have to protect each
other no question about it in terms of
mixing and matching you do get a
probably a slightly higher immune
response at a cost of slightly more side
effects i don't think it's a magical
thing to mix and match i would probably
stick to your original one if you can if
you got physio statifier if you got
modernist state of moderna if you've got
j j i think it's a little more variable
and you probably do get some more bang
for your buck getting an rna vaccine in
addition to the j j
what are some other protections that we
should be looking out for dr david
um you know as we get to holiday season
right we're going to thanksgiving we're
going to get to christmas case loads in
the united states are dropping we're
worried that another variant may come
but right now there's no variant that is
resistant to the vaccine we have to
continue to keep our guard up when you
go out to places where you're indoors
with other people please continue to
wear a mask if we can keep the spread
down we're going to have a much better
and more fulfilling holiday season for
all of us and i think we can get there
we can vaccinate these kids and then we
can really change our behavior keep it
with the mass on for another month or
two i think we're gonna be in a better
situation
dr david agus always good to see you
thank you very much